bientôt on s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur dernier match à mort un petit
fusil à pompe le persuade heures en plus
haut placé des mois on a fait une vidéo
de cinq ans directeur il met la pression
on avait fait une vidéo dessus il ya pas
mal de temps avec les copains est
actuellement bas y'a pas mes combats je
suis seul et je me prends bien là au
mont dieu alors ça ça fait mal à te à
bateaux mais qui m'a persuadé l'hôte en
premier et excellent jeu de mots ah bah
c'est moi qui lui ait apparemment nous a
pas vus aidez nous à vue il nous a vus
bordel il est où ils oublié partie par
là bas vieira petit [ __ ] hockey ou
l'a arrêté mais demander une serpillière
dans le jeu c'est complètement
scandaleux
il ya trop car là ça les connaît on
comprends plus ce qui se passe quoi moi
je vais camper bombay que moi je dis
c'est bien quand c'est le bureau sans
déconner c'est ma technique
moi j'ai pas vu l'autre mais là j'ai
soudainement et blanc cheater vasistas
où ils ont un beau lac je te perds soit
je te persuade je te persuade j'te
persuade m 106 kg là il n'y a pas de but
et bordel il à 106 kg de ce qu'ils
excellent jeu de mots à toi même les
pentes me disent tu es toi lucas sans
déconner et là je saute et hop là il
n'avait pas vu le court ils nous
apprennent tuer pour aimer grâce à lui
on fait une pause hyper s'il est ok on a
une photo génial pour le profil facebook
ça par exemple c'est une photo de merde
ça les personnes mais ça j'ai cru
l'avoir arrêté vous prenez un sandwich
je me barre me suis pas battue 106 kg
initiés savaient gavotte ban 106 kg ça
marche pas vrai je me suis goûteurs star
ac mais bon moore limite il est venu me
casser la tête avant de tirer quoi je me
marre au lac et al ouais moi aussi
j'aime pas le persuade heures moi ce que
je veux c'est celle et deux pistolets là
on a un petit style à tence et des
pistolets ou des mitraillettes avaient
on les a vus parce qu'on est il fait
quoi lui mais jean-michel mitraillette
tu vas être calmé direct voilà médiane
coupe le bras est carrément il a pas le
temps jean michel mitraillette moi je
veux changer de carte
regardez on laisse comprendre là sans
déconner oui entendait camper sur les
toits la tiens moi je te snack mon but à
athènes va tenter de monter là-haut au
but et on a réussi il y en a un là bas
le début
audio peut-être le pire aux oisillons
qu'on adore voyager pas purement
s'accroupir quoi laisse tout stopper net
nous laisse nous voilà c'est notre toi
tu t'en vas
coucou très bien ok jospin déjà temps
pour analyser mais il n'y a aucune
analyse possible dans le jeu quoi le
face à face ça ne marche jamais avec moi
quand je vais sauter sur un mur pour
sauter pour sauter pour sauter pour
sortir de la map je peux pas j'ai raté
j'ai discuté avec elle tire dessus je
veux juste la gymnastique devant lui
quoi et là on saute on fait ça on fait
ça et on est sur le toit et non autres
ont pu trouver quel flop tant peur et on
se calme et si vous faites trop de bruit
bordel ça suffit ok je ne sais pas
comment tu as fait voilà des qui est un
mec on lui fait deux tués en un mot le
plus gros des fours des fdp du jeu ça
c'est sûr et certain
et ça va quoi ralentir j'ai plus de mal
c'est bien dit
savoir jamais quand je fais ça bordel ça
lui met ça va au plat coup de crosse au
but un coup de crosse coup trop ce que
tu as à faire et qui met un coup de
crosse c'est gratuit 1 voilà on lui a
mis une petite fête qui veut un coup de
poing tu veux un coup de poing ou trois
mois
tu pourras jamais bonstein cas là on se
tue à la fin aux brigades
moi je suis contre une porte de garage
hier en plaques ou trois scouts france
excusez moi on a besoin de points de
suture pour un mec qui vient de se faire
défoncer dans l'arcade et on met des
points dont mais les bals de loin il
fait quoi lui elle est bannie il fait là
bas il est sur le web et ses coups de
crosse au pif coup de crosse
mais c'est l'énigme est mort c'était
quoi ça tue loup le renard dix de scènes
érotiques dans une cave
on va tuer la cible je sais pas pourquoi
fo le but et mais on va le tuer en mer
descend tout en bas des morts cette fois
vous allez tous décès c'est la fin on
est cinquième
ben tout c'est pas mal on va apprendre
la mitraillette toi jamais prise attends
attends juge apparaît dans une battle de
cowboy quoi coûte quoi olala on l'a
stoppé père dès l'âge et le point info
je vais le moins de choses fait partie
d'ailleurs mec
ok très bien c'est utile en avant les
points peuvent vraiment mais rien n'y a
pas eu fraude
faut arrêter de déconner un moment
franchement tu te calmes vincent coûte
quoi voilà tu te attend j'apparais ya
une d'un duel donc déjà on calme les
deux qu'est-ce qui fait acquis bolide au
dessus de tout quoi je peux rebondir
comme un aigle et l'actimel ce show ouaf
ouaf
alors le mec que je viens de tuer ce pas
lui qui visait en fait
j'adore voir des gens voler partout
comme ça c'est vraiment une passion que
j'ai développé dans la vie est en
moyenne et cet homme là sa crèche ou
bien de moi s'il te plaît alors lui
voilà on a eu un suicide en dix ans
c'est le leader l'idéal est décédé dans
l'eau est super tu fais quoi tu pourquoi
tu tires dans l'eau arrête ça suffit pas
de mon visage
ouais cet homme il va décéder ça et
c'est le même là ils sont prêts nombreux
rien à temps il quitte lui au le maquis
cheats et sur mer comme je me bats et je
vais manquer du spectacle on y va il est
où il est où l'état y campait 3 à quoi
je vais mettre là je vais attendre
ok et dès qu'il ya 20 ans appelant que
je défense s'est lui dit chip attend et
qui je suis sûr et certain et c'est un
[ __ ] de twitter le make up et
irritante sur lui-même à partir de là il
ya un gros problème quoi ou alors il a
un cerveau très très bizarre j'en peux
plus il est morte est morte et ont tué
on est coincé entre deux pièces
alors oui mais voilà j'ai aussi déjà fin
de cette mouture d'un malade c'est un
diamant biais d'un petit peu de style
aujourd'hui de s'éclater sur un jeu très
fun j'espère que vous appelez si ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude mais ça va regarder en
sortant celui attendant une prochaine
vidéo chat ou le monde passait j'ai
tenté une autre différente mais je veux
tout paniqué j'obéis à y passer une
bonne journée soirée matinée sur tout le
monde paie nuit tient tout le monde
puisque
je